Ya.
Sebuah quantum circuit bakal jadi unit nilai
buat bisnismu — qubit adalah unit informasi,
tapi circuit adalah unit komputasi.
Jadi yuk kita coba pahami apa itu quantum circuit
dan lihat anatominya.
Ini tampilan sebuah quantum circuit —
secara sederhana tersusun dari beberapa bagian: qubit-qubit
digambarkan oleh garis-garis horizontal ini. Dalam kasus ini kita menggambarkan
sebuah circuit yang punya empat qubit, yang bisa kamu lihat
di sini. Nah, gate-gate itu adalah
cara kita mengendalikan qubit,
dan kamu baca gate-gate itu dari kiri ke kanan.
Gate single-qubit bisa berupa gate
satu qubit atau gate multi-qubit.
Di sana kamu lihat controlled gate —
itu yang punya garis penghubung antara dua qubit,
dan di situlah operasi entanglement akan terjadi.
Dan terakhir, kamu punya pengukuran dan keluaran klasik.
Yang penting juga, kamu jalankan sebuah circuit berkali-kali
untuk mendapatkan hasil — dengan konsep yang disebut shots.
Jadi shot counter itu adalah berapa kali
kamu harus mengulang komputasi untuk mendapatkan hasilnya.
Oke,
seperti apa bentuknya?
Yuk kita lihat tampilan sebuah two-bit —
itu gambar yang tadi, kan — yang memperkenalkan perubahan fase,
dan tadi aku tunjukkan operasi yang melakukan rotasi tersebut
yang memungkinkan dilakukannya operasi interferensi itu.
Jadi mari kita bandingkan antara classical circuit
dan quantum circuit. Pada classical circuit, yang
kamu saksikan di sini adalah kamu nggak bakal lihat warna biru, kan?
Nggak ada rotasi, semuanya di sini berwarna merah muda.
Dan kamu cuma dapat state-state tunggal
yang di gate-gate ini tampak sederhana.
Tapi perhatikan betapa kontrasnya
kalau kita benar-benar mengimplementasikan sebuah quantum circuit.
Ini adalah circuit aktual yang kita jalankan di komputer kuantum kita —
yang bisa kamu coba juga.
Circuit-circuit yang akan kita buat
dengan kombinasi gate-gate tersebut
menghasilkan amplitudo kompleks penuh
dari gambar yang tadi aku bagikan ke kamu.
Kenapa itu penting?
Karena kita sekarang bisa menghasilkan relasi-relasi kompleks ini
antar qubit dalam hal fase
dan entanglement, lalu melalui tindakan pengukuran,
kita bisa meruntuhkan jumlah komputasi yang masif ini
yang sedang terjadi di dalam, menjadi
suatu jawaban yang penting.
Dan begitulah akhirnya kita sampai
pada jawabannya. Jadi kalau kita taruh berdampingan, secara visual saja,
kamu bisa merasakan bahwa classical circuit
nggak pernah bisa memanfaatkan ruang komputasi yang sangat luas
yang bisa dimanfaatkan oleh quantum circuit.
Visualisasi ini memberi kamu intuisi
tentang kekayaan cara kita mengakses ruang state yang besar ini.
Dan bagian yang indah dari ini adalah kita bisa
punya banyak kelas circuit untuk
melakukan fungsi-fungsi yang berbeda.
Misalnya, ini adalah sebuah circuit
yang dirancang untuk memodelkan risiko finansial.
Ini adalah contoh sebuah circuit
yang digunakan untuk pencarian dan optimasi masalah.
Dan ini adalah contoh sebuah circuit yang digunakan untuk
mensimulasikan sebuah molekul. Hal penting
yang perlu dipahami adalah kamu bisa merancang circuit yang berbeda-beda
untuk aplikasi yang berbeda-beda.
Circuit-circuit yang kita rancang kemudian direkam
dalam software dan disimpan sebagai software.
Dan dalam kasus kita, kita menyimpannya di Qiskit,
yaitu development kit open source kita untuk komputasi kuantum.
Ini adalah salah satu
framework software paling banyak digunakan untuk komputasi kuantum.
dan kamu bisa bayangkan membangun
library-library circuit yang tertanam dalam
program-program klasik yang kini menggabungkan yang terbaik dari pemrograman klasik
dan yang terbaik dari kekuatan kuantum.